get off tender you fake big dollop fake
[Music]
put it on someone else's windshield cuz
they'll pay it they won't look at the
number
they'll just hate and think they got it
I can't that it I know that sounded like
a joke but that is a great idea have you
done that before now are they scarecrows
work for dogs uh they work for dogs but
for not for dog crap if they have a dog
I think you want to do kind of martial
law quid pro quo with that one or do it
themselves to the neighbor
you mean defecate
well I'm following the law decided by oh
yeah that's the California well I don't
know what state you're talking about but
that's California law you're allowed to
go take and defecate on someone else's
lawn if their dog is that it's yours
yeah
it's it makes verbatim quoting it
[Music]
well what's taking so long yeah courts
you know probably just get married again
again despot a two-yard I had the same
problem with the when I came up with the
Diva Cup as you might not a decent of
this thank you
you know what it is no it's is it for
like physical in you not me uh yeah yes
Lily yeah okay
well you can't blame it on the shampoo
it could be a lot of things it could be
stress it could be someone could have
tampered with your shampoo
oh I pesky little sister
I don't think you can take legal action
I think maybe you just have to go back
to the beginning
find out where she lives and stick a
mega sign with like a toothpick in it
put it in the feces that says get off
tinder you fake this thing's about right
yes that's what I was gonna say but
let's say you have a law firm together
what would you call it soup plantation
and Rosberg soup plantation and Rosberg
yeah